- What did you do to make money,
like while you were, because
we all, I was a waitress.
I had like many jobs, but I feel
like we all were waiters at some point.
- Always.
- Yeah.
- I definitely have waited tables.
- Were you good at that?
- You know what I was good at?
I wasn't great at the
actual etiquette of waiting.
Picking up and dropping off
and putting, doing this.
- Yeah.
- I was good at observing
if a couple wanted to
be entertained or left alone.
- Oh.
- And I was good at noticing.
- Reading the room.
- Reading a room, and if we were late
in getting the food out,
I would just bring them
some shrimp cocktail
or something like, "I'm so sorry,
here's some something free."
You know?
And they were.
- Yeah.
- Very grateful for that.
So I kind of made up.
- That means you were a great waiter.
That was Yeah.
I want that waiter, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I feel like that's a great waiter.
- Well, I didn't wanna be a.
- Distract me while I'm waiting
on my food, yeah. (laughs)
- And I also loaded trucks
in downtown Los Angeles.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Andy Garcia was one of the
other guys down there loading.
- Doing it, doing the same thing?
- Yes ma'am.
- That's so crazy.
- Hard work.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And then I was a videotape interviewer
for a dating service
called Great Expectations.
(audience laughs)
- (laughs)The dating service
was Great Expectations?
I feel like you're setting
yourself up for failure.
- I know, no, those
expectations better be great.
- Did you reach them?
I know.
I'm just like, wait, so wait.
So here's the thing.
We got wind of this and
this is my favorite thing.
So you mean this service?
Roll the tape.
- [Narrator] You made a smart decision
by joining Great Expectations.
Now keep your positive momentum going.
Make sure to keep your appointment
for your photo and video.
And set aside some time to
read the Great Success Workbook
in your new member kit.
(audience applauds and cheers)
- Here's the thing
you were revolutionary
because here's the thing
now all these apps do exactly this.
- That's right.
- Like just in an app world,
you were ahead of the game.
- That's right.
You would slide right or slide left
but you didn't do anything in those days.
(Kelly laughs)
It's like, no, it was the
precursor to all those.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
You know, Match.com and things like that.
- [Kelly] I know, I.
- It actually worked really well.
- Did it, I was gonna ask, did
couples really come together
on that?
- And got married and.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- And yes, they did.
- [Kelly] Okay.